♪ ♪
>> Jesse: PRESIDENT’S DOLOMITE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN FIGHTING BACK BY
SUING
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND
CLAIMING THE LIBERAL PAPER IS
TRYING TO INFLUENCE THE OUTCOME
THERE WAS AN OVERARCHING DEAL
BETWEEN THE CANDIDATE TRUMP AND
RUSSIA TO HELP HIM IN THE 2016
ELECTION.
HERE’S THE PRESIDENT REACTING.
>> THAT GOT THE OPINION TOTALLY
WRONG AS "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
DID.
FRANKLY, THEY’VE GOT A LOT WRONG
OVER THE LAST NUMBER OF YEARS,
SO LET THAT WORK ITS WAY THROUGH
IT’S BEYOND OPINION.
THAT’S NOT AN OPINION.
THAT SOMETHING MUCH MORE THAN AN
OPINION.
THEY DID A BAD THING AND THERE
WILL BE MORE COMING.
>> Jesse: SO, EMILY, THIS IS
AFTER HE REPORTED THERE WAS NO
COLLUSION.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" RUNS A
COLUMN THAT THERE IS BASICALLY
COLLUSION.
IS THAT LIABLE IF THEY KNOW IT
IS WRONG AND DO IT ANYWAY?
>> Emily: WE WILL SEE IN THAT
LAWSUIT.
CERTAINLY, THAT’S WHAT THE
PRESIDENT THINKS.
IF I WERE HIM IN THAT MOMENT,
IT’S BASICALLY THE BASIS FOR
THAT LAWSUIT.
I WOULD HAVE SAID, LOOK, THEY
ARE CLAIMING IT’S MERELY AN
OPINION PIECE.
IF YOU HAVE MALICIOUS INTENT AND
YOU DISREGARD TRUTH AND
DILIGENCE AND YOU PUBLISH IT
ANYWAY AND YOU KNOW IT TO BE
FALSE --
>> Jesse: AND YOU KNOW IT IS
GOING TO HURT THEIR REPUTATION.
>> Emily: AND IT DID CAUSE
DAMAGE, YOU HAVE TO PROVE
DAMAGE.
THAT IS WHY WE ARE SUING.
THAT’S WHAT I WOULD HAVE SAID IN
THAT MOMENT.
I THINK THE ISSUE HERE WILL BE
WHETHER THERE WERE DAMAGES.
GO AHEAD.
KEEP PUBLISHING WHATEVER YOU
WANT.
OBVIOUSLY IT’S FROM 2019 PAIR
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY, IT’S THE
STATEMENT THIS MAKES, WHICH IS
THE PRESIDENT SAYING I’M SICK OF
THIS.
I HAVE ENDLESS BANKROLL FOR THIS
>> Jesse: WHY DO YOU THINK
THEY WANT TO ROLL A FAKE COLUMN
LIKE THAT?
>> Juan: I DON’T KNOW.
I DON’T SAY THAT YOUR OPINION IS
FAKE.
I JUST SAY IT’S AN OPINION,
JESSE.
I THINK THIS IS AN OPINION.
THIS IS A FRIVOLOUS LAWSUIT.
IT’S INTENDED TO INTIMIDATE THE
PRESS AND INTIMIDATE PEOPLE.
I THINK IT’S REALLY LOW GRADE
RED MEAT.
>> Jesse: CAN AND OPINION BE
WRONG IF THE FACTS ARE WRONG?
>> Juan: LOOK, IF THE FACTS
ARE WRONG.
AGAIN, "THE NEW YORK TIMES,"
THIS IS NOT A NEWS ARTICLE.
THIS IS AN OPINION PIECE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I’M REMINDED OF?
THERE IS GREAT PRESSURE ON
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL,"
BECAUSE THEY RAN AN OPINION
PIECE THAT THE CHINESE DIDN’T
LIKE.
THEY THREW THEM OUT OF THE
COUNTRY.
THIS IS AN INTIMIDATION TACTIC.
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" SHOWN IT
BACK DOWN.
>> Jesse: IS JUST MAKING THEM
BURN MONEY ON LAWYER FEES.
>> Dana: WELL, IT HURTS HIM
AND HE WANTS TO PUSH BACK.
WE CAN TRY THIS.
MIGHT NOT WIN BACK IN COURT, BUT
WE CAN TRY IT AND HE GETS A LOT
OF PUBLICITY AND WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT IT NOW.
I ALSO THINK IT HELPS
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
THERETHEIR SUBSCRIPTIONS HAVE GO
UP.
EVERYONE IN MEDIA DOING BETTER.
NOW, THEY CAN LET ALL THEIR
SUBSCRIBERS KNOW.
I THINK THAT THEY WILL FIND A
WAY TO PROTECT THEIR OPINION
WRITERS.
>> Jesse: OKAY.
GREG.
>> Greg: PROBLEM IS THAT THEIR
OPINION WRITERS ALSO REPORT.
I FIND THEIR OPINIONS ON THE
FRONT PAGE.
YOU KNOW THEY MEAN?
>> Dana: WHEN A NEWS REPORTER
WRITES ANALYSIS ON THE FRONT
PAGE, HOW ARE YOU SUPPOSED TO --
>> Greg: I DON’T WANT TO BE
SUED WHEN I’M WRONG.
BUT THEN AGAIN, LEGITIMATELY, I
ALWAYS ADMIT WHEN I’M WRONG.
I ADMIT THAT I’M WRONG ON
EVERYTHING.
IT ACTUALLY REALLY FEELS GOOD.
MAYBE IF THESE PEOPLE ADMIT THEY
ARE WRONG, HE WOULD DROP THE
SUIT.
IT’S PROBABLY THE BIGGEST STORY
IN THE MEDIA WORLD.
THE COVINGTON CASE CLUB SOLVED
OF THE VERY BAD ELEMENTS OF THE
MEDIA’S INSTINCT AND BIAS.
THAT GUY LOOKS BAD.
THAT OTHER GUY LOOKS GOOD.
THE STORY GETS ME EMOTIONALLY
EXCITED, AND MY STORY MIGHT
CATCH FIRE ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
SO, THAT’S HOW THAT STORY ROLLED
AND IT RESULTED IN A LAWSUIT
THAT THEY HAD TO SETTLE.
AND I THINK THAT HAS CHANGED THE
WAY PEOPLE LOOK AT THE MEDIA
THAT THEY CAN’T FIGHT BACK.
>> Juan: BUT I MUST SAY, ISN’T
IT IRONIC THAT REPUBLICANS WHO
ARE NORMALLY OPPOSED TO THIS
KIND OF FRIVOLOUS LAWSUIT,
DIGGING UP LAWSUITS ON PEOPLE,